[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
jeudi 23 novembre voici le programme de
ce soir les élections pour la présidence
du parti politique les républicains dans
les Yvelines débutent ce dimanche qui
succédera à Pierre Bédier deux candidats
se font face Philippe benasaya l'actuel
vice-président du département et Hotman
nasrou vice-président de la Région
île-de-fance ont fait le point en début
d'émission menace pour la biodiversité
coût des travaux disproportionné le
réaménagement de cette Mar au canard à
Chevreux fait polémique le projet
prévoit la construction d'un ponton et
d'une passerelle en colère les habitants
dénoncent un projet inutile et inadapté
ils ont lancé une pétition qui a déjà
réuni 10000 signatures le jeudi comme
d'habitude nous vous donnerons nos idées
de sortie pour ce weekend au programme
de ce soir de festival un de métal et un
de blouses de l'art et de la musique
mais aussi le spectacle de la Belle et
la Bête au château de maison la fite
nous vous parlerons également de
l'engouement autour du modélisme dans
les éolines ces trains et bateaux
miniatures ont la côte enfin en seconde
partie d'émission nous retrouverons
l'invité du 78 samedi 25 novembre c'est
la journée internationale de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
ce soir nous serons avec le directeur de
l'association France victime 78 pour
parler de son combat au côté des femmes
victimes d'agression il sera avec nous
en seconde partie d'émission avec moi
pour l'instant Gabriel Gontier bonsoir
bonsoir Mathilde comme d'habitude le
jeudi vous venez nous présenter vos
idées de sortie pour le weekend dans les
ivblines mais également les informations
du jour à retenir dans le département de
quoi est-ce que vous allez nous parler
ce soir et bien mathde on parlera
notamment du lancement de la grande
collecte annuelle de la Banque
Alimentaire ça se passe demain on
parlera aussi de cette étude de l'INC
qui vient de sortir d'après elle les
ivelinois seraient de grands adeptes de
la voiture je vous expliquerai ça dans
quelques instants mais avant nous allons
parler de l'avenir de la droite dans les
Yveline les adhérents du parti les
républicains 78 doivent choisir leur
nouveau président ce dimanche 26
novembre et lundi 27 novembre l'actuel
chef DLR dans le département Pierre
Bédier c sa place deux candidats se font
ainsi face- à face hman nasrou et
Philippe benasaya grégoryi canalé nous
aide à y voir plus clair la droite
ivelinoise face à un tournant après une
vingtaine d'années à la tête du RPR de
l'UMP puis des républicains 78 Pierre
Bédier ne rempile pas pour un nouveau
mandat deux candidats se font face pour
devenir le nouveau président de la
fédération départementale des LR
Philippe benasaya et otman nasrou tous
deux vice-président des républicains des
Yvelines et élu localement Philippe
benasaya veut mettre son ex expérience
sa contribution il a été maire de bois
d'Arc entre 2014 et 2020 et député des
ivelines pendant 2 ans entre 2020 et
2022 l'actuel vice-président du conseil
départemental est soutenu par Pierre
Bédier Pierre Bédier m'avait informé il
y a déjà des mois et des mois qu' qu'il
arrêtait le le le le la présidence des
des républicains 78 et je lui avais dit
si c'est dans ce cas-là si tu arrêtes je
souhaiterais je souhaiterais me
présenter
pour continuer travail mais renforcer la
dynamique et on en reparlera mais un peu
rajeunir les cadres et et trouver des
nouveaux moyens de milité parce que
parce que les républicains est sont un
parti classique conventionnel et c'est
vrai que quand on voit l'offre
aujourd'hui en France il y a des partis
qui ont adopté des des moyens de
militantisme beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
modernes face à lui Hotman nasrou proche
de Valérie pres Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France dont il est l'un des
vice-présidents le conseil municipal
d'opposition àrape était déjà candidat
en 2018 au côté d'Alexandra du blanche
il souhaite un renouvellement au sein de
la fédération moi quand j'ai fait cette
candidature je l'ai fait pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que j'ai considéré
qu'il fallait absolument qu'on refonde
la droite que le travail à faire était
colossal et que l'idée qu'on pouvait
continuer comme avant sans rien changer
est une idée suicidaire pour la droite
qui va disparaître si on ne se
renouvelle pas et si on ne va pas au
bout d'un certain nombre de convictions
et donc j'ai été voir absolument tout le
monde y compris Philippe benasaya et
vraiment tous tous les grands élus de du
de notre département pour leur présenter
ma démarche et j'ai tout de suite eu
beaucoup de soutien je souhaitais aussi
travailler avec tout le monde et je vous
le dis très simplement au lendemain de
cette élection si je suis élu je
travaillerai naturellement avec
absolument tout le monde le futur
président aura pour mission de donner un
nouveau souffle à la droite ivelinoise
en perte de vitesse de nombreux maères
les républicains encore mais aucune
circonscription décrochée lors des
dernières législatives et un nombre
d'adhérents en diminution dans le
département de 4600 en 2018 à près de
4000 aujourd'hui seul les adhérents LR
voteront en ligne pour ce scrutin
interne programmé les 26 et 27 novembre
allez c'est l'heure à présent de faire
le point sur les informations à retenir
aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines et on commence ces informations
Gabriel par la Banque alimentaire qui
lance sa grande collecte annuelle demain
oui Mathilde elle se déroule les 24 25
et 26 novembre comme chaque année vous
pourrez retrouver les bénévoles équipés
de leur gilet orange dans de nombreux
magasin pour récupérer des produits
alimentaires et d'hygiène l'an passé
l'initiative avait permis de couvrir 10
% des besoins d'approvisionnement soit
24 millions de repas pour la Banque
Alimentaire Paris Île-de-France 117000
bénévoles sont déjà mobilisés une
collecte d'autant plus importante avec
l'inflation car les prix des ressources
augmentent ce qui fragilise la Banque
Alimentaire vous pouvez aider la
collecte pour sa rendez-vous sur le site
jeeveuxaider.gov on poursuit ces
informations avec une pétition lancée
par par le maire des clés sousbois
Philippe guigen oui après le courrier la
pétition Philippe guigen appelle tous
les élus de France à signer et à relayer
cette pétition pour engager une réforme
des mécanismes financiers en octobre
dernier on le rappelle il avait déjà
adressé un courrier au président de la
République pour dénoncer le
désengagement de l'État sur les finances
des collectivités locales et malgré le
réchauffement climatique nous serions de
plus en plus nombreux dans les iblelines
à avoir une voiture oui Mathilde je vous
en parlais d'après une étude de L c'est
plus on s'éloigne de la capitale plus la
part des ménages équipés d'une voiture
augmente en 2019 le taux d'équipement
automobile dans la grande couronne était
de 83,4 % pour 33,5 % à Paris et alors
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer cet
écart et ben justement selon l'INC tout
dépend du profil du ménage les personnes
qui vivent au moins avec un actif ou qui
résident dans une maison détiennent le
plus souvent une voiture l'âge du ménage
a aussi son importance car à partir de
55 ans le taux d'équipement automobile
progresse on poursuit avec une bonne
nouvelle Gabriel le 30 novembre prochain
Paris 2024 mais en vot en vente 400000
nouveaux billets pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris 2024 oui une bonne
nouvelle et il faudra être à l'heure
parce que les places sont sont seront
mises en vente sur le site de paris 2024
à 10h elles sont prévues pour assister à
n'importe quelle compétition sportive
sauf le surf car la réservation n'est
pas obligatoire sachez que la vente
concernera aussi les rencontes compte
qui était en rupture de stock pour ce
qui est des primail ils sont plutôt
abordables un/ers des billets seront à
50 € et près de 2 tiers à moins de 100
€. j'ai déjà mis une alerte sur mon
téléphone personnellement d'autres
billets sont aussi mis en vente Gabriel
ce sont ceux de l'électric Park festival
oui il s'agit des passes confiance si
vous faites confiance aux organisateurs
et que vous souhaitez prendre vos places
avant même de connaître la programmation
c'est possible et ce dè maintenant ces
passe confiance VIP comprennent des
espaces privés des bars ou encore un
accès gratuit aux animations les billets
sont disponibles sur shotgun.live le
festival aura lieu les 30 et 31 août
2024 vous avez un peu le temps merci
beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous l'envoyer
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78
news d'ordinaire si paisible la colère
gronde en Vallée de Chevreuse les
habitants ne comprennent pas le projet
de réaménagement de la m au canard mené
par la mairie si les travaux pour
construire une passerelle et un ponton
sont déjà en cours les tensions
persistent les chevrotins dénonce un
projet inadapté inutile et trop coûteux
c'est le reportage de Julien Leroi et de
Aurélie
lafelle une passerelle un ponton un
marrêt et un nid d'observation supérieur
à 3 m de haut auteur prendront place
dans cette mare au canard à chevvreuse
un projet entrepris depuis août 2023 par
la municipalité sur ce point d'eau de
3000 m² ce projet est critiqué depuis sa
mise en place par l'association
Chevreuse environnement et patrimoine
selon eux l'écosystème a été détruit
l'association craint une forte
augmentation du nombre de visiteurs car
le site est au pied de la Vallée de
Chevreuse Chevreuse environnement et
patrimoine est une petite association
très récente à Chevreuse et a eu l'idée
de lancer cette pétition en ligne pour
dire son opposition au projet
d'aménagement de la Maroc canard dont le
chantier a été lancé récemment on se
trouve face à un écosystème qui est
extrêmement perturbé et qui sans doute
se reconstituera puisque la nature est
résiliente mais était-il nécessaire de
créer tous ces tourments à la nature
pour un projet d'aménagement dont la
pertinence
échappe la pétition a recueilli 10000
signatures mais pour la mère de
chevreuses ce chiffre est à sous-évaluer
dans ces 10000
personnes je sais pas si vous avez
regardé de près il y a du Guatemala du
Canada l'Afrique du Sud enfin des gens
signent de partout donc ça déjà je suis
très heureuse de voir que les enjeux
environnementaux intéresse bien au-delà
de nos frontières l'ambition c'était de
remettre en valeur cet espace de manière
à ce que tout le monde puisse y trouver
son compte avec un volet environnemental
un volet biodiversité et égal un volet
pédagogique les travaux sont estimés à
plus d'un million d'euros les
subventions s'élèveront à 280000
€. si vous êtes à la recherche d'un
emploi restez bien attentif le
restaurant américain olis dinner
s'implante aux clés sous-bois début
décembre et l'enseigne recrute 30 postes
sont à pourvoir en cuisine en salle
ainsi que pour le personnel encadrant
Grégory canalet est allé à la rencontre
du directeur général du
[Musique]
restaurant c'est un concept de
restaurant américain des années 50 60
donc vous allez retrouver chez nous tout
l'univers Mariline monau Elvis pressley
la musique le cinéma on ouvre un nouveau
restaurant dans le centre commercial
alpha par le 6 décembre au clés
sousbois pour l'ouverture du restaurant
on recrute environ 30 personne en
cuisine et en salle donc il y a à peu
près tous les postes les postes
d'encadrement que ce soit chef de
cuisine second chef de partie mais
également directeur ou directrice
adjoint direction leader et mais aussi
des serveurs bien entendu des cuisiniers
des commis sales ou des commis de
cuisine vous pouvez encore postuler il
reste quelques postes en salle
essentiellement et on cherche uniquement
des CDI temps complet
39h
plusieurs créneaux on va dire soit sur
indid soit avec le Pôle emploi soit sur
notre site internet
olisdiner.fr mais également en postulant
directement venant au restaurant ou sur
l'adresse mail
olisplaisir@olisder.fr allez comme
chaque jeudi c'est l'heure à présent de
passer à notre page
loisir
[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisir avec vos
idées de sortie pour ce weekend Gabriel
on commence avec de la musique oui
mathila avis aux fans de métal le
festival mettal spère revient DESS
vendredi et jusqu'à samedi soir au
programme de jours de concert dédiés aux
musiques extrêmes et au métal parmi les
artistes rage behind novelist ou encore
le groupe de butchers Rodeo je vous
propose qu'on écoute un extrait
mes anées noir de regret
[Musique]
dé organisé par masos et la batterie les
concert auront lieu vendredi dans la
salle de la tour à voisin le Bretonneux
et samedi à la batterie de Guy en cour
des places sont encore disponibles et
toujours en musique mais dans un autre
style ce weekend Gabriel c'est la fin du
festival Blues sur scène oui et il vous
reste trois dates Mathilde avant la
clôture du festival vendredi AHR vous
retrouverez les Lemans broser samedi
soir c'est dirty deep qui se produira à
Limet dernière date dimanche à 17h à
mantelaville avec en première partie
Lucy un groupe yvelinois depuis 24 ans
le festival itinérant blues sur scène a
pour vocation de développer la musique
BL dans le mentoi depuis sa création
plusieurs centaines d'artistes
internationaux et français se sont
produits dans la vallée de la scène
direction Chantelou LVG à présent pour
les fantaisies musicales 2023 oui samedi
à 20h l'orchestre classique de
l'alliance se produit au centre
artistique le Phénix de Chantelou lévgne
au programme une soirée de concert avec
pour thème la rencontre de la musique
classique et des valeurs de l'olympisme
engagé et innovant depuis 2017
l'orchestre de l'Alliance propose des
concerts itinérants dans les evelines
objectif partager la musique classique
avec tous les publics même les plus
éloignés après la musique de l'art ce
sont les derniers jours pour profiter de
la 23e bienénale d'art photographique du
chaîné rquencour oui et cette année ils
étaient 51 photographes à avoir répondu
présent pour exposer sous forme d'un
quatre images entendez quatre images
cohérent pour partager une émotion un
souvenir un regard ou un moment dans le
temps pour clôturer l'exposition photo
photographique qui a lieu tous les 2 ans
le chénero cancour accueille samedi
Olivier Morin reporter photographe à
l'agence France Presse depuis
1990 invité d'honneur de cette édition
il viendra échanger avec les visiteurs
autour d'une conférence et vous
souhaitiez terminer avec une dernière
idée Gabriel au château de maison la
fite oui pour terminer Mathilde je vous
propose un spectacle immersif pour
redécouvrir le célèbre compte de la
Belle et la Bête pendant 1 heure au
travers d'un parcours spectacle au sein
du château de maison une quinzaine de
scénographies retrac la célèbre histoire
d'amour une parenthèse animée par le jeu
d'une d'une centaine pardon d'acteurs
costumes décor accessoires et musique
l'immersion est complète l'occasion de
savoir s'ils vécurent vraiment heureux
jusqu'à la fin des temps on regarde la
bande
[Musique]
annonce il y a quelqu'un
je tiens à connaître le visage de
l'homme à qui j'abandonne ma
vie bon et puis pour les plus terre à
terre c'est aussi l'occasion Mathilde de
redécouvrir le Château de Maisons sous
un autre regard et bien merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces idées
est-ce que vous êtes fan de modélisme
alors fan je sais pas en tout cas on l'a
découvert grâce à nos invités la semaine
dernière c'était plutôt intéressant mais
en tout cas ça fait fureur dans les
evvelines Gabriel l'engouement est bien
présent le weekend dernier deux
événements ont lieu à fontenelfleuy et à
montinie lebretonneux un rendez-vous
très attendu par les passionnés Mélanie
poket et Régine ralèche sont allés à
leur rencontre Jacques est tombé dans la
marmite depuis tout petit passionné des
chemins de fer il a intégré les
passionnés du train une association de
modélisme ferroviaire ça permet
d'aborder tout un tas de techniques
différentes la menuiserie le décor
l'électricité l'électronique quelques
mètres plus loin c'est une histoire
similaire que raconte herwan ce
passionné a commencé à construire son
bateau à l'âge de 15 ans un bateau qui a
nécessité plus de 500 heures de travail
herwan a réussi à transmettre sa passion
à son fils ah j'ai mon fils qui est qui
est derrière moi et enfin qui est dans
dans qui s'occupe de l'écollage pour les
petits avec son B on l'avait construit
ensemble quand il avait 4 5 ans il a
fait un autre voilier entre 7 et 8 ans
et maintenant il donne des des conseils
au petitjeunes pendant les expos du côté
de fontené lefleu c'est l'aviation qui
fait rêver l'association modélisme et
loisirs techniques promeut le modélisme
aérien quand on a les jeunes c'est aussi
voilà on part au début de quelque chose
qui fait rêver un avion qui vole puis
ensuite on va plus dans le détail avec
eux de pourquoi ça vole comment on le
construit et comment voilà on les a on
les acc agne pour voilà pour que
éventuellement ça puisse devenir une
passion la passion dépasser les simples
exposants à Montini le Bretonneux plus
de 5000 visiteurs sont venus admirer les
modèles en 2024 le club de Fontenis le
fleurri organisera les championnats de
France et c'est bientôt l'heure de
passer à l'invité du 78 mais avant je
vous propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de
demain demain matin le soleil devrait
revenir dans les Yvelines du côté de
Versailles et de Mantel jolie par contre
le ciel sera toujours bien couvert dans
le secteur de rambouillé et de haudans
au niveau des températures il fera en
moyenne 9°gr sur l'ensemble du
département dans l'après-midi le soleil
sera présent dans toutes les Yvelines
côté température compter 9 à 10° en
moyenne et concernant les prévisions
météo de ce weekend samedi profitez bien
du soleil il sera là toute la journée
niveau température ça se refroidit d'un
coup compté en moyenne 4°gr le matin et
7 de degr l'après-midi dimanche la
grisaille sera de retour et les
températures seront également froides
couvrez-vous bien il fera en moyenne
3°gr le matin et 6°g l'après-midi c'est
l'heure à présent de passer à l'invité
du
[Musique]
78 samedi c'est la journée
internationale de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes pour en
parler avec nous Jonathan portier
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
de l'association France victime 78
depuis le début de l'année 95 femmes ont
été tuées en France par leur compagnons
ou leur excagnons ce chiffre vous évoque
quoi euh ben c'est un chiffre terrible
euh qui pour le coup devrait pas exister
mais qui qui malheureusement existe
encore euh donc c'est vrai qu'il y a des
des des changements au niveau des des
politiques d'aide aux victimes qui qui
vont en faveur de de cette protection là
pour éviter d'en arriver là mais
malheureusement on est encore encore
confronté à à ce fléo aujourd'hui quelle
est la situation dans les ivelines
est-ce que la tendance baisse ou elle
augmente c'est alors c'est difficile à
vous répondre puisque euh nous d'année
en année effectivement on reçoit de plus
en plus de personnes euh après vous dire
si c'est une augmentation des faits ou
alors une une libération de la parole
euh là c'est plus difficile de juger en
tout cas de plus en plus de personnes
bah s'autorise à parler et et à dénoncer
les faits en tout cas ça prouve bien que
cette journée internationale de lutte
contre les violence faites aux femmes
elle est toujours primordiale
aujourd'hui effectivement ça permet de
bah de remettre aussi sur le devant de
la scène un petit peu cette
problématique euh même si c'est devenu
quand même une priorité aussi au niveau
gouvernemental pour l'opinion publique
aussi c'est important à ces occasions là
d'en reparler de de resensibiliser aussi
le public et si vous êtes victime ou
témoin d'une personne en situation de
violence conjugale plusieurs numéros et
sites internet existe dans les Yvelines
ils sont en train de s'afficher
n'hésitez pas à vous faire aider au sein
de votre association Jonathan portier
comment est-ce que vous soutenez les
femmes qui sont victimes de violence
alors nous on a deux volets d'in
intervention on a des des juristes et
des psychologues donc les les juristes
ont pour mission de bah d'informer les
les victimes sur leurs droits que une
procédure judiciaire est été lancée ou
pas euh pouvoir accompagner dans ces
démarches judiciaires donc pouvoir faire
aussi le lien avec les autorités police
gendarmerie
tribunal et du coup on a le volet aussi
donc psychologique avec des psychologues
qui sont voilà spécialist dans le le
traitement du psychotraumatisme et qui
vont pouvoir accompagner dans la durée
euh les victimes pour passer au-delà si
je peux dire de des conséquences de
l'infraction et pouvoir aller mieux au
quotidien et justement les femmes elles
peuvent venir à n'importe quel moment
franchir les portes de l'association
elles seront toujours accueillies alors
ça dépend des des lieux de permanence
mais effectivement on a des lieux sans
rendez-vous et avec rendez-vous euh donc
le mieux ce soit effectivement de nous
appeler nous contacter par mail pour
pouvoir prévoir un temps aussi dédié
pour pouvoir accueillir la parole et
pouvoir enseigner au mieux vous mettez
en place aussi des groupes de parole de
la sophrologie de la self défense tous
ces outils tout sont nécessaires c'est
des outils complémentaire effectivement
par rapport au aux missions principales
qu'on peut avoir euh on s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait aussi des besoins
qui pouvaient être autrre et donc on
essaie de de développer des dispositifs
qui vont venir compléter un petit peu
cet accompagnement et et participer à la
reprise un petit peu active des
personnes victimes dans dans leur vie
combien de femmes vous avez accompagné
environ cette année ou l'année dernière
euh alors effectivement la l'année
dernière sur la la thématique des des
violences conjugales intrafamiliales on
a accompagné à peu près 1500 personnes
1500 personnes c'est c'est un chiffre
conséquent c'est en hausse enfin tout à
l'heure vous nous expliquez c'était
compliqué dévaluer mais au niveau local
c'est en hausse c'est stable en tout cas
nous au niveau de
l'association ça augmente effectivement
un peu plus chaque année euh c'est vrai
nous on regarde aussi ces chiffres de
près puisque notre association elle est
dite généraliste puisqu'on accueille
toutes victimes d'infraction pénale donc
pas forcément uniquement que les les
femmes victimes mais du coup ce ce
public là représentait moi quand j'ai
commencé il y a il y a 8 ans maintenant
un peu moins de 30% du public qu'on
qu'on accompagné maintenant on est à
plus de 40 % et vous arrivez à suivre au
niveau bah du nombre de bénévoles ou de
personnes qui vous aident au sein de
l'association oui du coup là on a une
équipe salarié qui s'est renforcé
d'année en année actuellement on est
trois psychologues trois juristes et et
moi la direction et aussi de formation
juriste donc qui tient aussi des
permanences au quotidien vous parlez du
chiffre très important est-ce qu'il y a
un profil type où ça touche vraiment
toutes les classes sociales ça ça touche
tout le monde pour le coup c'est vrai
que c'est un peu des idées qu'on peut
avoir que ça peut concerner bon déjà
soit que les femmes mais qu'une
catégorie de de classe sociale ou autre
et en fait on se on se rend compte nous
en pratique que quel que soit le le
milieu dont on vient en fait ça peut
arriver et d'après votre expérience
est-ce que c'est toujours un tabou de
dire à ses
proches j'ai été battu ou je suis battu
par mon conjoint il y a une appréhension
effectivement
du regard de l'autre la peur d'être jugé
c'est ce qui aussi peut empêcher les
personnes d'en parler autour d'elle mais
aussi de de faire les
démarches et la la peur aussi de ne pas
être cru et ça peut du coup toucher
n'importe quelle femme comment faire
pour que ça s'arrête
euh déjà en parleroup je pense que c'est
la la première étape nous on se rend
compte que la démarche même de d'appeler
l'association qui un confidentiel
sécurisant et compliqué donc on essaie
d'avoir aussi une une action un peu
proactive envers envers les personnes
victimes effectivement se tourner vers
vers les acteurs qui peuvent accompagner
à la fois au niveau psychologique
juridique mais aussi social qui va venir
de façon globale accompagner et aider
les les victimes dans leur démarche vous
parlez des acteurs est-ce que vous
travaillez en étroite collaboration avec
les autres associations du département
la préfecture le tribunal la police oui
c'est vrai que dans les iblines on a
cette chance en tout cas d'avoir un un
maillage entre les les partenaires qui
qui est très présent très fort donc en
fonction des secteurs on a des des
réseaux aussi qui se sont créés sur la
thématique des des violences conjugales
et qui va permettre aux professionnels
qui ont des difficultés par rapport au
aux personnes qui peuvent recevoir de
d'échanger un petit peu sur ces
problématiques et ensemble trouver des
solutions ce qui permet après au
quotidien de de fluidifier aussi les
orientations et et euh et du coup
permettre un accompagnement qui est qui
est global et justement on parle des
femmes et derrière ces femmes il y a
souvent des enfants également est-ce que
vous les prenez en charge ou vous les
vous les tournez vers d'autres
associations alors autant qu'on est en
capacité de le faire on on peut puisque
notamment je pense au au volet
psychologique où o les psychologues
peuvent accompagner les les enfants à
partir de 6 an après on a que trois
psychologues donc qui vont pouvoir
prendre en charge que une personne de
chaque enfin un membre de chaque famille
donc s'il y a des des demandes avec des
familles qui sont plus de trois on va
après se mettre en lien avec les autres
associations des detin du département
pour
pouvoir proposer aussi un accompagnement
à toute la famille et bien merci
beaucoup Jonathan portier d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions alors je
le rappelle si vous êtes victime ou
témoin d'une personne en situation de
violence conjugale n'hésitez pas à vous
faire aider plusieurs numéro s'affiche
sur votre écran c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
et une bonne fin de semaine prenez soin
de
[Musique]
vous